we have all endured a very unusual year
it's been much more difficult for some
than
others but i think collectively there is
a sense of loss a sense of grief um
i think we're all trying to process it
in real time
and because it's so unprecedented we
don't have
lifetime experiences or benchmarks that
we can
look back upon or rely upon in order to
figure out
how to chart the course forward and i
feel like
there's this i see this in myself or i
feel this in myself
this urge or compulsion to just kind of
get excited about the world opening back
up right now and just say wow that was a
crazy year like that's in the rear view
let me compartmentalize that and let me
just move back into doing what i was
doing before
but there is a powerful residue i think
that we're all carrying
and short of really confronting that
in a meaningful way and working through
the complicated emotions of what we've
all
experienced in our individual ways we're
cutting ourselves short from
a proper healing so that we can be whole
as we
kind of walk back into the world
what you just described in the pandemic
sense is exactly
what we were just addressing in an
individual kind of grieving sense for
example you said a moment ago
that sometimes with
a deep grieving situation families
splinter
and what you just described
as a couple of options right
compartmentalize move forward
is oftentimes what
sort of aids in that disintegration
because when you compartmentalize real
events
that are not over with when they're over
because there's just such a long tail
that follows the event they once said
that
death is like a crocodile or an
alligator
that the death is in the head
but for that to leave the room there's
that
long body and long tail and in that
process of it leaving the room if you've
compartmentalized it
there's a lot of unresolved emotions as
you well know
same kind of thing that takes place in
um the sober world
right the the the unprocessed emotions
compound build up yeah and then when you
don't process them in a
in an event upon
event upon event kind of way
it's just happen chance as to whether or
not you can get through it
um and what i find is that that event
upon event upon event kind of way
needs to be in big communication like we
were
with my daughter son-in-law my wife
his parents so that and and the other
children
and the same thing is true in the
pandemic yeah i mean there's this
you know it with this compulsion to just
move forward
we have to reckon with what's going on
and i can't help but
but you know lay that across the tableau
of sobriety because that's my reference
point but
yes you know the analogy would be you
get sober and you think the problem is
drugs and alcohol and suddenly you're a
raw nerve and you have all these
emotions and they're spilling out all
over the place and
you don't know what to do with them uh
and the steps
are a methodical way of getting you to
confront
those difficult things that you've
compartmentalized or
the mirrors that you don't want to look
into and helping you
deconstruct those so that you can
develop a greater self-understanding
while in parallel giving you tools for
how to work through them so that you can
become
essentially a whole person and they're
so powerful
and and also simple in many ways that i
feel like
everybody could benefit from learning
about them and practicing them
in their own right but the pandemic
provides this universal opportunity
because it's been such a collective
global experience for all of us
to you know reckon in a methodical way
with the you know various forms of
trauma that we've all experienced so
that we can
we can get back into the world and on
some level perhaps even be
better or more equipped you know better
equipped to handle
significant stressors as we you know
mature through life
thank you for drawing the parallel to
sobriety
and the world of addiction because
weren't we all addicted to what we
called normal
right and all of a sudden
we got sober shall we say
from normal and
here we are with all of the emotions
that were being satisfied
by our consumption of normal and and and
this compulsion to relapse on normal as
an anesthesia for having to feel these
things that we're feeling right now
yeah and that's that is like a relapse
isn't it
for example the bubonic plague
lasted for about a decade and a half you
know and
of course they had less technology then
and so moving through it was much more
difficult
but following the bubonic plague was the
renaissance
i mean people were so pent up that going
back to the normal
what happened politics changed because
the monarchy was no longer going to be
in charge of these people that have been
that had been suffering at the doorway
of death for a decade and a half
music changed art changed science
changed religion changed the gutenberg
press
came in the the romantic composers and
artists came in
i mean the pent-up energy just spewed
into all of this science and technology
and art
here we are again yeah the optimist in
me
really wants to see our version of that
renaissance
transpire i think the differentiator
here is that we have this thing called
the internet
and as powerful as it is in terms of
connecting all of us
uh you know the the pessimist in me sees
the extent to which it divides us and
um the means by which it puts us against
each other
and instead of you would think when
we're having a collective global
traumatic experience that we would unite
and rally
uh around a solution it would bring us
together
instead i see quite the opposite
and so when i think about that in the
context of
a modern-day renaissance i wonder how
that might pan
out yeah whether we're we're even in a
position to
have that kind of experience given the
way you know our current operating
system functions
that's beautiful
[Music]
you